Conan: Alright, Ladies and Gentlemen, Justice League, let's get Zack Snyder to the stage!
(Audience Cheers and Applause)
Justice League director, Zack Snyder, thank you for being here again, sir!
(more cheering)
Now, uh, yeah, that's the intro
Zack: Does this work?
Conan: Works better than this one
Uh...Now Zack, I'm told that you have a little bit of a surprise for us, is that right?
(excited cheers)
Conan: Well, I'm told if you, you know, it;s good to have you here and you wanna bring some people out, is that right?
Zack: People? I thought you were gonna bring the people out?
Conan: I will bring 'em out but I thought you were gonna say, "Hey, let's bring people out."
Zack: Oh, hey! Let's bring some people out!
Conan: Yeah!!
Woo!!
Zack: Now, you guys, I'm sorry, I'm a little delirious but we were literally shooting the movie
Conan: Backstage?
They were backstage shooting the movie
Zack: I was like, CUT! Okay, run now on stage!
Conan: Let's get 'em out here, Ladies and Gentlemen
Ben Affleck!
Wooo!!!
Gal Gadot!
Ray Fisher!
Ezra Miller!
and Jason Momoa!!!
(Conan laughs)
Conan: Ladies and Gentlemen, the Justice League!
(more cheering)
(more laughter)
Conan:  I love Jason's hat! That is the greatest hat!
Well, y'know, Jason's touring with the Charlie Daniels band this summer
Zack: No, no!
(more laughter) Zack: Y'know, I mean, it's kind-..... I mean..it looks...it's Justice League
It's Justice League-esque or -ish
I mean, traditionally, I don't know, the Justice League has an additional character
But... (Conan) Yeah, but we all know that character died
(Conan) He did, he died. I saw the film
Zack: Oh, in the movie?
Zack and Conan: Yeah
Zack: Well, I mean there was a small...
There was a..
I mean like, I don;t wanna ruin it or anything but...(cheering)
I mean...
You gotta have Superman!
(erupts in cheers)
Zack: (Please) welcome Henry Cavill !
Conan: No!
Conan: What?
(more cheering and applause)
(Conan chuckles)
Yeah, a'right, gotcha (3x), we're good
Conan: I think you have a little something now that you were, uh, we're all here now
Zack: Let me get this right, you...you think that we would show footage now?
Conan: Now.
Conan: I would think having these people here in person would be enough
Zack: Yeah, it seems like... I mean..(Conan) That's all you need to do is have the people here
You would not need to show any footage
Zack: I mean, we've only been shooting for like, 2 months?
Alright, we shot a small..we kept together..a teeny.. it's really just a taste (audience cheers)
But, um, yeah so..
Zack: We should show it? Alright, we should show it!
Conan: Let's give it up for the Justice League!
Conan: Justice League opens November 17th, 2017
Thank you all for being here! (Zack) Thanks guys!